why do you have to be friends you have
to want to chat to each other I mean
before just before I came into this Judy
I had a chat to Mary about one or two
things if you don't want to chant any
longer it's all over we've been married
for 42 years and I'm looking forward to
going back next Saturday we've already
booked the theater we going to saturday
night we all both know where we're going
to have lunch on Sunday so and if you
didn't want to do that after 42 years
better to pack it up I mean I'm I don't
like the concept of divorce but I
understand people having to part when
they no longer friends well I think you
have to make a lot of sacrifices and I
have you think you have to be very
understanding you have to it's quite
hard for human beings to sit down and
think what will suit the other side
better than me what can I do that will
make it easier for her and you've got to
be thinking that all the time and it can
be in such simple things would it be
better if I left my car at home so that
she can come up to London in the car
would it be better if she went by train
that they often very mundane simple
things would it be better if I rang an
hour later when I know she'll be coming
out of the hospital she works in a
hospital or would it be better if I rang
before she went you've got a often it's
simple things think about of the
problems the other person is facing
member